I think I could speak for all the World
Bank employees.
It's a,
it's a job that is a very,
it gets,
it grabs you really strongly and you,
you do get up early in the morning and
you look forward to the day are very
interesting work because what could be
more interesting than to work on some
hundred and 50 countries on the boat,
a hundred sectors,
uh,
and on global issues,
from such an outpost as the World Bank,
which is owned by 195 countries of the
world and from which you do look at the
world as if it was a whole planet.
Uh,
not from the country point of view but
from a sort of overall global point of
view.
So it's a very interesting job to be in
and you get to learn a lot of things
about a lot of countries and a lot of
people and the culture of the
institutions is interesting.
It's one where there are 150 or 60
nationalities in the house and you never
think about the nationality of your
colleagues.
You forget about it.
Everyone has the same jargon.
And codewords and you forget that
someone is Italian or Bangladeshi or
Tanzania.
And so it is a little bit,
it has the culture of the world as I
would wish it to have.
I would wish to world had that sort of
culture one day.
Uh,
it's beyond the Knight Nation State and
the nationality culture.
It's sort of one level above.
And that also makes it very fascinating.
And the third thing that,
uh,
had me taking at the World Bank,
it's very libertarian institution.
There was a lot of room for debates on
what worked and what didn't work.
They were a lot of arguments,
academic arguments or even practical
arguments one way or the other.
And you could do many things.
And I did in my time,
uh,
I pioneered many new things and I was
never whistled back in that way.
That was part of the reasons why I saw
like the institution
[inaudible].